how's everybody doing i'm dalton i'm a
partner at y combinator
um in addition i'm the head of
admissions um which is our selection
process for the companies that get into
yc
i am here to talk about pivoting um
yeah let's talk all about pivoting cool
all right here's some stuff we're going
to cover what the heck is a pivot
why you should pivot when you should
pivot and evaluating ideas to pivot to
so we're going to try to cover all the
bases here all right let's talk about
the term pivot um
this is one of those terms that if i'm
in a cafe and i hear someone talking
about pivoting
i roll my eyes because it's one of those
words uh that i associate with annoying
startup people
um and so let's let's just uh explain
what we mean here
it just means changing your idea that's
all it means and
technically if we want to be really
technical i would call a true pivot
where it's like a real company and you
have lots of users and you've raised
money
and you're like we're gonna shut this
thing down and do something different so
the most famous example is
slack they raised money and had like a
hundred employees for this video game
um called glitch i was a beta user and
then they one just shut it down and like
did something crazy
i would call that a pivot i think that's
a valid use of it probably what
most of the folks here are doing i
interchangeably call it pivoting but
you should just call it changing your
idea um
it should feel really lightweight when
you're at the earliest stages of your
company especially pre-launch or very
near
after launch changing your ideas
constantly is kind of the
the norm and i wouldn't think that this
is some huge thing it should feel
lightweight
and frankly if you're not in a state
where you're rapidly changing ideas or
assumptions over and over and over again
in quick succession
you are likely doing it wrong you are
likely moving too slow
and so this is just like part of it
change your idea constantly
um trying to find exactly the right
version of your idea is something you
should be doing in the beginning
let's talk about why you should pivot
so the main reason i would argue is
opportunity cost
and the definition of opportunity cost
is that
the loss of potential gain from other
alternatives where one alternative is
chosen
so in other words you can only really
work on one thing at a time
sometimes people try to violate that
rule but that's a whole different topic
and so by working on something that's
not working and you have evidence that
it's not working
you are taking opportunity costs to not
be doing something else it's as simple
as that right
i don't know i tried to to write some
pseudo code here for you about a
you know it's a kind of a joke um but
like how well things are working divided
by the number of
months of concerted full-time effort if
that number is less than
excitement to work on something else
plus confidence you can find something
better you should pivot
and so the key thing to if you like look
at this equation like what am i really
trying to say
it's that if you've worked on something
for months and months and months and
months and it's not
happening like that's a pretty good
signal
right like that's what drives this
equation that i put here the most is
the number of months you worked on
something and it's not working um and so
if you're
throwing good good money after bad good
time after bad and it's not happening
for you
that is a pretty darn good signal but if
it's really really really early and
you've only been working on something a
couple of weeks
it's less obvious let's give you some
good reasons to pivot
i hate working on it all right
it's not growing it's just not working
i'm keep doing the thing and nothing is
happening
i'm not a good fit to be working on this
idea like the more you learn about this
the more you realize that you are just
not the right person for the idea
another one is i'm relying on an
external factor outside of my control
to make my startup take off so a couple
of examples of that are like
relying on mainstream virtual reality
headset adoption
that's a good one you know like any day
now the new facebook
thing's gonna take off and and you know
that's when my vr app's going to take
off
or like relying on like mainstream
crypto adoption things like that um
those are like totally out of your
control and if you're just sitting here
hoping someone else does something good
and then your startup will work man you
should definitely pivot
another one is just where you're out of
ideas on how to make the thing work
you're just
you've thrown everything against the
wall to make your current idea work and
you're you're actually kind of out of
ideas that's usually a sign you should
pivot
good reasons to not pivot um you're
trying to run away from doing hard
work sometimes you see people where they
build a product and right when it gets
to sales time they pivot
and they do that over and over again
that's probably not a good reason to
pivot it's just someone trying to dodge
the sales part
um so watch out for that um also another
reason not to pivot is if you're you're
the type of person that changes their
idea over and over and over and over
again
like chronically um and you're detecting
yourself doing that it's good to
actually follow something through
all the way so you just want to watch
out for that happening
also um a good reason not to pivot is
that like
you know you just hear there's some hot
new thing and you want to pivot because
you write a techcrunch article because
someone raised money for a hot new thing
that's not a great reason to pivot let
me give you some reasons on why people
take too long to pivot and the reason i
mention this is i would
argue on average most people take too
long to pivot
right i think that's usually like if i
had to put people in buckets
more people take too long than uh than
the reverse and so why do they take too
long
loss of version when you feel like
you've invested in something you have a
really hard time letting go to it and
that's loss of version you can you can
research this
um have a little bit of traction like
you have a few users or like one
customer
you're like maybe it'll work that will
make you not pivot
um and that's that's rough um
another thing is like people are very
polite in the world and they have a hard
time telling you the truth
that they don't like the thing that
you're working on um and so a lot of
founders get confused about politeness
um and getting that confused with
traction and so you're never going to
really i mean
maybe i shouldn't say never most likely
you're not going to have people being
like your idea is horrible
give up now i will never be a customer
they're not going to tell you that to
your face they're like oh this is great
maybe if you add a few more features and
come back you know we'll take a look at
it
right oh that's dangerous because you
can end up doing that iteratively over
and over and over again for like years
and never actually get customers so
watch out for politeness
and getting the politeness confused with
traction another one is a fear of
emitting weakness or defeat if you pivot
you're giving up in some way
another one is putting blame on why
things aren't working on
um customers or investors so this is
where you're like i'm not wrong the
world is wrong
you know like no one gets this this is
like way ahead of its time
um things like that are not a not a
great sign
um and usually people realize that maybe
it is kind of on them versus on the
external world but it takes a long time
to get there
and then finally there's a lot of
inspirational stuff out there that's
just like if you just believe hard
enough and keep going
you know the you'll eventually be
recognized and everything will be great
um and so there's a lot of those
inspirational messages out there and
that can kind of be counterproductive
i don't know this is super eligible but
basically this is where i talk about the
little bit of traction thing
i call it the uncanny valley of product
market fit um
and you know what's weird i noticed this
at yc as a yc partner
someone that gets into oic with an idea
that's just a
total fail like immediately is actually
the huge advantage
than someone that has like a little bit
of traction isn't that weird
like a total fail the founders can
declare bankruptcy on the idea
immediately and just work on other stuff
with no regrets
and no like second guessing oh should i
pivot you know they're like wow that was
really bad
and having that freedom to immediately
throw off the old idea and work on a new
one
is actually a weird advantage isn't that
counter-intuitive and so you just want
to really watch out for
a little bit of traction because i've
seen that be a trap that have
captured a lot of really talented people
for long periods of time
and then let's just talk about the
anecdotes um
so anecdotes about you know stories of
people that just kept doing what they
were doing and it didn't work and then
five years later you know it was great
i think those are cool and they're
inspirational and i like them and i
they're all true you know they're
anecdotes but it's kind of like
anecdotes about people that
you know played the lottery every day
for like five years and then they won
the lottery and now they're like really
happy
and you know that's super cool but that
is not actionable for you
right there's nothing you can do with
this anecdote about someone that like
just kept believing
strong enough um like
i would much rather give people advice
to play the statistics of this
and to take accountability for like
their own actions in the world
than just like hope and dream that you
might be one of the anecdotes too
and so if you decide to pivot or don't
decide to pivot just remember
you decide it's your life and if it
works out
good or bad that's on you and so
often i get founders that want to push
this decision on
me as a yc partner or other authority
figures about is this idea working or
not when should i know when to give up
and ultimately all we can do is give you
guidance but this is exactly
in the class of problems that is on the
founder and never something you should
look to an authority figure to tell you
how to decide
product market fit i'm sure you know
we're talking about this a lot it's been
discussed a lot in
startup school and it's because it is so
important most people will never get it
probably most people watching this don't
have it even if they think they do
um and you know you have it when growth
is not your biggest problem it's other
stuff and one good reason to pivot is
you just get more shots on goal to try
to get this elusive thing
right like if you made something and you
launched it and it's like
man not really working um a dang good
reason to pivot is you get another roll
of the dice you get another shot
and so i've just seen people that use
these opportunities really well
it's much easier to be lucky when you
get like half a dozen shots on goal than
one
right and so just if we're just playing
the statistics of how do i get product
market fit
taking several high quality shots notice
i say high quality you can't just
constantly pivot through stuff another
launch it but if you do a full
awesome product iteration of making
something completing it
shipping it giving it to people
following all the device you're looking
here
and you can give yourself multiple of
those shots i would argue you are
creating luck for yourself and the odds
that you actually hit something that
works
are much higher than someone that only
ever takes one shot
okay let's talk about how to find a
better idea um here's the advice that i
give people during the batch
when they are looking for an idea to
pivot to um
find something that you're more excited
about and that makes you more optimistic
about the world and more
just generally more excited to wake up
in the morning and work on the thing
and not less excited and there's a
corollary here and this i think is
counter-intuitive
often choosing what is perceived as a
harder idea
is more uh is is good
and so i see a lot of people where
they're like working on some like ad
network ad tech thing to like
affiliate something ad targeting i don't
know
those like never work and it's because
they're not inspirational and no one
cares
and so when you see people go from that
into something that's really really
exciting
right like oh i want to help small
business owners do
x or i had a company in this last batch
um
and they did uh they started with um
this ad tech thing that they were all
very bored with
and they pivoted to robin hood for india
and the moment they pivoted to that
they the founders they were like they
lit up and every conversation i had with
them they were like
so excited about their idea and it was
contagious talking to them
um and it was almost like a different
like the amount of change it was the
same founders but what changed is they
found an idea that was real that they
were excited about
and not just some like boring ad tech
crap no one cares about that stuff
okay so if you're doing something that
seems like a good startup idea because
you're writing techcrunch people raise
money for it but it's not inspiring
to you and you're like man this is
pretty lame you probably want to find
something that's more exciting to you
another thing to do on a finding a
better idea is make an honest assessment
of what you're good and bad at
this is hard but you want to be really
self-aware of what you're good and bad
at
and play to those strengths and another
thing here for finding a good idea
is especially if it's a pivot find
something that you can very quickly
build and validate and not something
that takes like a year or two of r d
right often like if you pivot from one
thing that's impossible to ship into
another thing it's impossible to ship
not good ideally you find something
that's way easier to ship
like really fast highly recommended
quick note here
caveat it's totally okay to work an idea
where you're not going to raise venture
capital all good
most businesses in the world don't
require venture capital and so all of
your
if what you're doing is consuming lots
of content on how to start a
company like this and it's all kind of
like venture capital focused stuff
um and you're not going to do something
that raises venture capital you can kind
of get blown off course
idea wise and so
just be self-aware about this and
realize that if you do want to raise
venture capital
the idea does matter a lot and there's a
constant
like recurring theme i see is people
that are trying to raise money
for something that is definitely not
venture capital fundable
and they get really frustrated everyone
gets frustrated with that it just it
doesn't make sense for all businesses
and so just be self aware of this when
you're choosing an idea of like
is this something that at least
hypothetically is vc fundable
just to give you some rule of thumb what
does that mean um
i don't think there's a guidebook for
what venture scale means but uh here's
some rules of thumb
can i imagine this business generating
hundreds of millions or billions in net
revenue per year
that sounds venture capital fundamental
um can i imagine
the revenue growth to get to those
numbers to happen in like less than 10
years or five years like can it happen
really fast
can i imagine this thing that i'm doing
is a publicly traded company someday
can i picture it can i visualize it
kevin's first lecture talks about this
but these are all things like if you
just
can't see any of these that's not a
great sign and
other key properties is usually
technology is a key component
and usually the founders build the
technology at least in the early days
for something to be vc fundable um you
want to see really high margins
not for everything but again just a rule
of thumb software margins you know
80 gross margin seventy percent gross
margins really high margins to some of
you we wanna see
and then um just it's funny like i think
a lot of people learn about
fundraising from shark tank and i don't
think a lot of that stuff is venture
fundable just in case you were wondering
um it's it's fundable for people that
want to put product stuff together but
i don't know if you know i think you'd
have a hard time raising money for
venture capitals for the majority of
that stuff
but hey like i said earlier it's your
call it's your it's your dream so figure
it out
when's the best time to pivot as soon as
these things happen
you've launched and trying to get users
for weeks or months and you feel
hopeless
it feels hopeless you should probably
pivot when the idea is impossible to get
started with
like cool once we raise 100 million
dollars then we will build a prototype
you should definitely pivot if you're
one of those people because unless you
have 100 million dollars you are in a
chicken and egg
unsolvable issue and here's another one
you know when you're hurt it's not going
to work a lot of founders know
secretly that their thing isn't working
but they want to keep up this front to
everyone in the world that it is working
and they think they can fool people into
funding them or working with them
if you can't convince yourself and you
know this isn't really working
man is that a good time to pivot right
like you know more than anyone else
about your business you gotta listen to
yourself
and it's sometimes not stuff you want to
hear
from yourself um okay
let's talk about other epiphany stuff if
you pivot over and over and over again
it causes whiplash
whiplash is very bad because it causes
founders to give up and not want to work
on this anymore and that actually kills
the company
weirdly it's more deadly to your company
to get whiplash
and get sad than to work on a bad idea
because if you're having fun working on
a bad idea you won't give up and then
conceivably you can maybe make it work
if you get really sad and hate your life
while you're working on your startup you
will definitely not succeed and it's
because you will give up
and so this is weird like it's kind of
better to work on
an idea that's not the best one if
you're really having fun
um and then you just want to be in a
happy medium
some founders pivot way too much and
they'll probably watch this lecture
and then like pivot once a day for six
weeks don't do that
and some people just work on the same
idea for five years and it's not working
and they just are really opposite about
it
just find the happy medium like
everything else in life
another thing is it's really hard to
have employees and be pivoting so don't
do it
it just makes it slower and it makes
them really sad and so trying to scale
up like a team
and taking all the advice here about how
to scale a team while you don't even
know what your idea is or you think
you're going to change your idea
definitely not best practices
it only slows you down i would only add
people to the team
after you know your idea is working and
you have confidence otherwise
it's just all downside okay let's go to
a different thing here
i made this up for this lecture and i
came up with a subjective
notion of a quality score just to give
you a few
criteria to evaluate an idea okay
and so what i did is there's you know
four key things that i think you could
use to evaluate the quality of an idea
and you could give them a one to ten and
then you average those together to give
an overall quality score
okay so let me just go into detail on
these how big of an idea it seems to be
and again this is the stuff i talked
about earlier is this an obvious
publicly traded
company like um i don't know
tesla hey it's a new car company there's
lots of publicly traded car companies
that seems pretty big
a new bank there's lots of banks that
are publicly traded that seems pretty
big
uh the opposite of the spectrum is like
um i don't know
a franchise subway i'm gonna buy a
subway franchise you know um
you know that's that's the under the
spectrum or like oh i'm gonna import
some stuff and sell it on ebay
you know probably a little a little less
obvious how it's big
um the cyclone founder market fit is
really really key so again a 10 out of
10 would be
hey i was on the self-driving car team
when i was an undergrad and then i
worked on self-driving cars my whole
career and so now i'm gonna do a
self-driving car startup yeah that's a
ten out of ten
a zero out of ten is like i'm going to
do some kind of advanced ai startup
and i don't know how to program that's a
zero out of 10 right there don't
recommend that
how easy is it to get started on lda is
actually i think undersold i don't know
if people realize this is actually
really key um is ideas that are easy to
start
are highly recommended and there's so
many really good ideas out there
that never work because the founders
can't figure out how to get started and
then someone in the future does the same
idea and has a much better way to get
started and then they win
and then people get bitter because
they're like i had that idea
so i would argue getting find an idea
that's easy to get started with
um is just as important as the idea
itself and finally
early market feedback from customers
this just means does do people just want
it immediately in a sales
straightforward
or is it just impossible so let me give
you some examples of companies that i
worked with and advised at yc that you
may or may not have heard of
brex is one um they're in yc117 and
they're i funded them to do a different
idea
um and talk to them a lot during their
pivot and they pivoted during the batch
and they got product market fit pretty
quickly and
they have now raised hundreds of
millions and worth billions in two years
so it's like
one of those rare outlier stories i'm
not saying this is common
but holy cow i got a front row seat to
watching
kind of the most epic pivot of all time
i think maybe there's other ones but i
was like wow
that really worked so let's talk about
the before and after
here was what they started with they had
this idea for a new
vr hardware headset that you would
use to do work or something um
and so if you here's the scores i just
put in you know i put these in now these
i didn't do these at the time but how
big does it seem yeah it seemed like
medium big like vr headsets
i don't there's no publicly traded ones
but that seems like the future right
um founder market fit uh i gave a one
out of ten these guys knew nothing about
hardware or
optics or any of the things associated
they were just fintech software folks
so they had literally no idea what they
were doing and they were very upfront
about that
um how easy it was to get started that's
only a two and the reason is
they had to hire hardware people to
build a prototype not a good sign
they needed millions of dollars to build
a prototype not a good sign and it would
take like years and years and years of
manufacturing
so this was pretty bad um and then
finally early market feedback
they went and talked to people and
they're like do you want to use this and
no one wanted to use it
so this was bad okay so overall score
two and a half out of ten okay post
pivot
credit card for startups that seem
pretty big
there's tons of publicly traded comps of
like fintech companies you know again
even in startup plan there's
there's square there's stripe i mean
there's lots of examples of that so i'd
give that a 10 out of 10 i did at the
time
founder market fan 10 out of 10. uh i i
the reason is they had started a fintech
company earlier in brazil
and it was successful and they sold it
for like 20 or 30 million so they knew
exactly what they were doing and they
could write all the code themselves
and they could ship it themselves and
they had all these existing
relationships
man is that such a better fit um how
easy was to get started i'm only giving
this a three out of ten
because they actually it's hard to
launch a new credit card product
this is one where if you aren't don't
have founder market fit i would not
necessarily try this at home
um there was something about the founder
market fit that made it easy and then
finally the early market feedback i'm
giving eight out of ten
and it's because in the batch they were
like hey do you have a credit card
do you want to be a customer and people
were like yes
and that was a whole sales process like
i witnessed it multiple times so if
if that's your sales process good
it's like a three sentence sales process
and people say yes that
is good let's talk about retool they're
winner 17
and they're a really good sas company
and honestly everyone should check it
out and maybe use it it's a tool to
build internal tools it's awesome
um i'm encouraging all the yc startups
to use this to build internal management
pages
it's it's actually like a really great
product so um that's what retool is you
should look at it
prepivot was venmo for the uk um
how big it seems seems pretty big like
venmo is big um
found a market fit three out of ten they
didn't really know anything about
fintech
but they managed to get a launch there
was something there how easy it was to
get started i'm giving that a seven out
of ten it's because they already
launched
they'd already had a bunch of users then
so that was pretty impressive and
you know early market feedback though
was only three out of ten and the reason
is
no one wanted to pay and they were
losing money on every transaction so
there's all these reasons this wasn't
really working
and so they decided to pivot even though
this is an example of
the insidious sword attraction
right they had enough traction that it
was like hard to decide to give up on
this
because they had users and it was like
kind of working so that was a tricky one
anyway retool post pivot is the no code
internal tools bill
folder i think it seems like a 10 out of
10 because 80 of all software built is
for internal consumption not external
consumption like a big companies
and so that seems like a big market to
me find a market fit 10 out of 10
one of the founders had made something
like this it is college internship
and so he had a very good idea of what
the product should be and had relevant
to it um it was easy to get started they
built it in two weeks and got their
first customers
great and early market feedback only
given a 5 out of 10.
people were interested in it but they
weren't sure they wanted to trust some
new startup to this thing so if this one
did not fly off the proverbial shelves
they managed to get some users but it
was not immediate obvious product market
fit they had to build it out a bit
so that was a great pivot next we got
magic they were in winner 15
they pivoted during the batch and what's
great about them is they built a
profitable and sustainable company
yay i wish we all could do that right um
how did they do it they started off with
this idea for a blood pressure coach
where there was an app and you enter
your blood pressure and it would tell
you how to lower your blood pressure
um didn't seem like a huge idea
uh two out of ten final market fit they
didn't know anything about health
whatsoever or
much along those lines so that's
probably just a two out of ten
how was he was he started eight out of
ten because they built the app really
quickly and they got users really
quickly and they followed all the advice
good for them
and then the early market feedback was
like not good everyone was really polite
and no one used the dang thing like
their usage was just horrible
so this one was again was kind of
obvious they should pivot they realized
it on their own pretty quickly
and then they built a bunch of
prototypes they actually built the magic
prototype in a weekend
no joke this is actually true uh not an
exaggeration and they put it on hacker
news
and it went to number one and got like 2
000 up votes and it blew up overnight i
don't know if anyone remembers this
thing but it went like crazy viral
um and they got all this press like it
was the most
it was an example of a shots on goal
thing i was talking about earlier where
they didn't know like they they had like
five ideas and
there's no way i would have known they
would have known that this would be the
thing that would capture the world's
imagination
but it did and so not obvious founder
market fit on this one either but it was
very easy to get started it got really
good early market feedback and it seems
pretty big so that was great it also
inadvertently
inspired tons and tons of clones so i
would argue that anyone that's doing
chat bot stuff
it's sort of like a direct descendant
about when this thing blew up and
everyone's like oh chat bots for the
future
uh was sort of like second order effects
from this going so crazy viral and
inspiring so many people
segment they're in yc summer 11 they
pivoted a bunch of times
including years after the batch it took
them a really long time to get it going
they didn't even pivot during the batch
and now they're worth billions and it's
a really good company
um it's a top data infrastructure
company so pre-pivot they had this thing
that was a classroom feedback tool
where like you would give it to students
in a classroom and they could say
if it was if they were lost or not i
think was what the feature was
um so if you were confused you would
like push a button and it would tell the
professor
okay didn't seem huge um
in my opinion finer market fit well they
were students and they were young so i
would give that like a five out of ten
they weren't experts on education but
they understood the audience
um it was easy to get started they built
it really fast
and the early market feedback was
actually decent where professors liked
it and they got a bunch of schools to
adopt this thing so their sales were
successful
but ultimately this was not you know it
took them
on the order of years to discard this
one um
and yeah this was it's good that they
pivoted because now they're doing
segment
again which everyone should use uh it's
a data collection tool
that one did not seem obviously big have
anyone here use segment it's this
javascript thing you put on your page
and it
connects to other tools it was less
obvious how that would be a publicly
traded company at the time
but the final market fit was great
because they built so much analytics
stuff they were world experts on
analytics already when they built it
it was easy to get started because they
literally built this thing and open
sourced it and gave away for free
and people begged for them to support it
like the market begged for this product
to exist they didn't think this was the
company they just had this like thing on
github
and so many people were obsessed with
this thing that they built they're like
well i guess the market's telling us we
should make this the company
and they did it so that i would say is
uh easy to get started and
really good market feedback you know
with the markets begging for something
and that you don't even think it's good
enough to convince you it's good that's
a pretty good sign
and so that was a good pivot okay
in summary i tried to give you those
examples just to give you real real real
life examples of stuff that i personally
worked on
just to show like the before and after
and how these decisions are really made
and so changing your idea is part of a
startup
the sooner the better because of the
opportunity costs and the shots on goal
type of stuff
and when you're considering changing
your ideas especially the early stages
it shouldn't feel like a big deal you
should probably do it all the time
and following best practices is
recommended hopefully i gave you some
good pointers on what those best
practices are
but if you're really scientific about
this you can dramatically increase the
odds
that your startup will work great that's
it for me
thanks
you